what's up
hey
leave him
what's the matter with you guy are you
so bored
I did
yeah
hey hey hey
hey
hey hey stop that I see that there is a
huge escalation from the Israeli
soldiers and the Israeli settlers to
wear it Palestinian and Israeli human
rights Defender we are now really have a
real life threats I feel my life is in
danger what happened that the soldier
was wild and he didn't care about the
presence of a a prominent International
journalist they don't care they don't
care anymore even about about the
cameras about journalists they feel that
they are backed up with their own
government and backed up by their own
system
foreign
[Music]
I talked to the IDF spokesman and he had
misrepresented the facts of the case
by saying that the soldier was
performing his regular duties and that
Issa was cursing him and provoking him
that's not true the entire episode was
initiated by the soldier himself
foreign
it shocked me really to my core that
people can do that to each other because
this Soldier is also normally a human
being and but I think they are
that's brainwashed that they don't see
like Palestinians as human beings
anymore there is a dehumanization that
is incredible and we felt that in that
moment that he was treating Issa as like
I have to say it like an animal who has
to be tamed
foreign